[Musique]
une nouvelle édition du journal sur tv
fil 78 au cours du prochain quart
d'heure nous allons faire le point sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale voici
les principaux titres de ce mardi 27
septembre 2016 il n'avait connu
quasiment aucun travaux depuis 1975 au
lycée franco allemand de buc va subir un
sérieux lifting le coût de l'opération
devrait s'élever à plus de 43 millions
d'euros répartis notamment entre
départements et régions peu plaisir
prépare la deuxième édition de son bike
and run run and bike un événement qui a
l'an dernier avait attiré quelques 460
participants dans le parc du château et
puis elle nous terminerons ce journal en
musique avec les dimanches musicaux de
coignières qui reprennent ce week end un
rendez-vous qui met l'orgue à l'honneur
pour débuter ce journal pour débuter ce
journal donc nous allons nous diriger
vers la commune de buc une commune où se
trouve depuis 1975 le lycée
franco-allemand qui va connaître
d'importants travaux de rénovation un
établissement qui attire près de 900
élèves ils seront plus de 1300 à l'issue
du chantier mais ce n'est pas tout
puisque le gymnase va être reconstruit
et les experts extérieurs réaménagés
reportage camille lambert et michael et
demi dont
ils datent de 1975 et n'a jamais fait
l'objet de grands travaux le lycée
franco allemand de buc va être rajeuni
les façades seront rénovés pour un
aspect plus moderne et de nouvelles
salles vont être construites une volonté
de l'établissement et du département de
proposer un bâtiment en accord avec son
époque le talisman comme il est
aujourd'hui n'étaient plus adaptés aux
nouveaux besoins aujourd'hui il ya un
gros développement sur les
développements numériques toutes les
salles sont câblés demain il y aura des
tablettes quasiment partout les élèves
et aujourd'hui les infrastructures ne
perdais ne permettait pas ce déploiement
du numérique
début des travaux au printemps 2017 le
bâtiment actuel sera restructuré une
extension de cinq mille mètres carrés
sera construite le projet prévoit la
création d'une salle de musique une
autre de sciences et d'un cdi autre
nouveauté une salle polyvalente d'une
capacité de 300 places
la restructuration est importante parce
qu'elle va nous donner des
surfaces supplémentaires de manière à
pouvoir monter en puissance au niveau
des effectifs ce qui nous donnera aussi
des possibilités de rentabiliser nos
options bouvry peut-être l'une ou
l'autre option est en tout cas d'étendre
notre offre de compléter une offre
vis-à-vis de notre deux élèves avec
l'école primaire et le collège
l'établissement accueille en tout plus
de 800 élèves avec ces travaux il espère
porter ses effectifs à 1200 chiffré à 40
millions d'euros le chantier devrait
être terminé pour la rentrée 2010 9
économie à présent est la success story
de ce groupe familial électrogènes aux
depuis soixante dix ans cette entreprise
est spécialisée dans l'impression et sa
filiale j'étais prins porté sur le
numérique est installé sur la ville de
trappes elle vient d'ouvrir ses portes
au public le reportage de nicolas qui
rit lot
impressionnant cette impression
numérique ou encore création d'affichés
l'électro gélose expose ses savoir-faire
pour ses 70 ans et pour l'événement les
clients peuvent découvrir les machines
et les 1800 m² de la nouvelle filiale
j'étais print une entreprise installée à
trappes depuis 1968 et qui permet au
groupe de compléter l'offre de ces
services soient les clients viennent
avec un brief ou alors juste avec une
idée on va leur proposer donc la
création de ces documents dans le but de
faire soit du web soin d'imprimer
ces documents sur différents supports
luxe btp pharmacie énergie les clients
de groupes septuagénaire se sont
diversifiés avec le temps les demandes
également tous nos clients nous confient
énormément de typologie de travaux
différents ces travaux vont de la créa
l'impression offset pour les gros
volumes des volumes moyens voire des
volumes à un exemplaire et dans des
formats aussi atypique que là tout petit
format une forme des coupes particulière
ou une très grand format et on se charge
aussi de poser la signalétique on a
imprimé chez nos clients le groupe
électro gélose compte désormais 300
salariés dont 45 pour sa filiale
trappistes une filiale qui réalise
jusqu'à 7 millions d'euros annuels de
chiffre d'affaires
et puisque l'on parle économie sachez
que le chômage progresse également dans
les yvelines 2 1% toutes catégories
confondues sur le mois d'août un chiffre
est néanmoins inférieur à cette moyenne
nationale qui s'établit donc à 1,4 pour
cent le département compte dorénavant 94
1650 chômeurs pour la ministre du
travail mme myriam el khomri l inversion
de la courbe du chômage et malgré tout
engagé si l'on se base sur les chiffres
de l'insee est depuis un an sur le
terrain les actions se multiplient
malgré tout exemple avec le club face de
saint quentin en yvelines qui va
dorénavant intervenir au niveau du
département tout entier le club fasse
dans l'objectif est de favoriser
l'engagement social et sociétal des
entreprises pour lutter contre toute
forme d'exclusion de discrimination
encore de pauvreté
son président au niveau local est
intervenu sur notre antenne c'était hier
c'est surtout les actions en fait qui
vont être déployés sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines là on a
commencé à déployer des actions cotées
menthe les mureaux poissy et puis
l'objectif à terme c'est de pouvoir
effectivement d'être présent sur
l'ensemble du département des yvelines
alors ça a été préparé en amont je
suppose avait déjà nommé d'autres
partenariats avec avec d'autres
entreprises qui sont injustement plutôt
du côté nord des yvelines oui tout à
fait en fait avant le démarrage de cette
de ce projet d'extension on a rencontré
différents partenaires et notamment des
entreprises puisque l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir fédérer et d'accompagner des
entreprises autour de notre action donc
on a rencontré un certain nombre
d'entreprises on a rencontré également
un certain nombre de réseaux
d'entreprise pour avoir un mouvement un
collectif pour porter ensemble
effectivement cette extension entretien
à revoir en intégralité sur notre site
internet grâce au replay 2 informations
politiques à présent à vous donner
sachez tout d'abord que le député des
yvelines udi arnaud richard va remettre
dans les prochains jours un rapport sur
l'accueil des migrants se sera
emmanuelle cosse et claude bartolone
l'élu plaide notamment pour un partage
des difficultés avec une répartition des
migrants au niveau national et des
quotas par région pour les encadrer
arnaud richard souhaite aussi faire
appel aux unités du génie de l'armée les
associations étant débordée précise-t-il
et puis à voisins le bretonneux
l'adjoint délégué aux finances charles
de batz vient de remettre sa démission
au maire est l'élu qui dénonce de
mauvaises pratiques je cite contraire à
son éthique personnelle la mer alexandra
rosetti qui évoque évoquerait également
ait des désaccords sur la façon de mener
la politique des ressources humaines
notamment avec cet élu un nouvel adjoint
aux finances sera en tout cas est
désigné lors du conseil municipal de ce
27 septembre on passe aux sports à
présent le samedi 8 octobre prochain se
déroulera la deuxième édition du run and
bike au coeur du parc du château de
plaisir coureurs et vététistes main dans
la main osman vendeurs d miquel et demi
d'euros pour cette présentation de
l'événement la run and bike est de
retour à plaisir avec 460 participants
lors de la première édition la
municipalité a décidé de renouveler
l'expérience et des nouveautés sont à
prévoir nous allons augmenter la
distance donc nous sommes passe à 15 km
le 12 km au départ nous avions fait ça
pour rester quand même sur un point
moyen pour pas qu'il y ait trop de
difficultés et pour pouvoir attirer
justement des participants suite
retour d'expérience nous avons jugé
utile d'augmenter la distance passer à
quinze kilomètres ce qui reste quand
même une bonne moyenne le concept du run
and bike remporte un tel succès que
plusieurs villes ont déjà organisé comme
versailles ou encore mort pas cette
course vous pouvez la faire en vélo ou à
pied la volonté des organisateurs c'est
de la rendre accessible au plus grand
nombre il ya plusieurs courses 1 vous
avez le 15 km qui est par le matin c'est
la première course c'est là où il ya le
plus d'inscrits c'est celle qui qui
intéresse le plus grand nombre ensuite
vous avez une course de 7 km 5 qui pour
les jeunes de 14 à 18 ans et pour les
adultes aussi qui permet à voir d'avoir
aussi des équipes mixtes adultes et et
adolescents et dans la premier l'après
midi vous aurez deux courses pour les
enfants qui s'adresse aux enfants donc
une course de 4 km et une autre course
de 2 km la deuxième édition du run and
bike aura lieu le 8 octobre si vous
souhaitez participer rendez vous sur le
site de la mairie de plaisir
sport toujours l impact djo à présent
nous en avons déjà parlé sur cette
antenne mais au lendemain de l'événement
alors un mois plus tard cet impact est
il durable quelles sont les disciplines
qui profitent de l'effet rio 2016 les
éléments de réponse avec mickaël millero
la france a vibré au mois d'août au
rythme des jeux olympiques avec 40
millions de téléspectateurs en audience
cumulée sur l'ensemble de la compétition
certains sports ont pu se voir offrir
une fenêtre médiatique
une exposition qui a un impact sur les
clubs locaux en termes de licenciés le
judo porté par un teddy riner médaillé
d'or chez les plus de 100 kg s'attend à
voir arriver de jeunes judokas
contaminés par larry nemanja ya beaucoup
de gars marché nous dit moi je vais être
ceinture noire pour ressembler à teddy
riner
autres sports boosté par les géo la boxe
la france a collecté six médailles dont
deux en or pendant cette olympiade tony
hawk à originaire des yvelines est
devenu une superstar de la discipline le
boxing club de saint quentin en yvelines
s'attend à accueillir 40 % de licenciés
supplémentaires pour cette nouvelle
saison j'ai eu beaucoup de coups de
téléphone des gens
voilà je pense qu'on va ce
sera difficile vu la taille de la salle
mais on peut même doubler l'effectif
qu'on a là on a à peu près 120 licenciés
on peut arriver à le doubler mais après
faut pousser les murs
l'équitation sport pratiqué par plus de
680 mille licenciés dont 22 milles dans
les yvelines devrait également profiter
des trois médailles glanées au brésil
par les cavaliers foncé il est très
difficile à évaluer parce qu'on est déjà
le troisième foire nationale en nombre
de licenciés est le premier chez les
filles donc c'est un peu compliqué les
globes sont pleins à craquer puis il
faut avoir aussi là la cavalerie pour
pour assumer assumer cette augmentation
donc c'est c'est difficile à évaluer
mais effectivement on sent que il ya du
on espère en tous les cas qui aura un
effet plus haut niveau de la
médiatisation pour un bilan définitif
sera dressé dans tous ces sports d'ici
novembre avec la fin des inscriptions
annuelles
pour terminer ce journal un peu de
musique à présent depuis près de vingt
ans l'association des amis de l'orgue de
coignières propose des concerts pour
cette saison 2016 2017 rendez vous
autour de l'orgue au sein même de
l'église de la commune que vous voyez
sur ces images cela va débuter ce
dimanche 2 octobre avec le trio akuila
écouter jean yves est ess pièce est le
président de l'association est au micro
de mélanie poker de ce qu'on veut
montrer c'est que ce n'est pas qu'un
instrument d'église c'est un instrument
à part entière
certains parlent du roi 2
le dise l'orgue c'est le roi des
instruments donc cet instrument à part
entière et on le montre entouré de deux
de différents instruments merci de nous
avoir suivi tous nos reportages sont à
retrouver sur le
www.td.com 18 points comme vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux au
rendez-vous et 18 heures mercredi pour
un nouveau point sur l'actualité locale
ce sera avec florane parfait
[Musique]